bonjour internet ya deux jours j'ai
sorti une vidéo sur les techniques de
drague d'un certain williams a fait
polémique chez certaines personnes
j'avais envie de vous en parler puis on
est sur internet voilà je veux prendre
la parole quand jouer sur la chaîne
youtube pour échanger avec vous alors
j'en profite pour quoi j'ai fait cette
vidéo il ya un peu plus d'une semaine
j'ai découvert la chaîne de williams et
j'ai beaucoup ri en écoutant ses
conseils de drague prendre des douches
accosté diffame pas rejoué femmes aiment
les chemises de couleur vire je me dis
qu'il ya matière à faire une vidéo
marrante en se moquant gentiment sans
être méchant et puis quelques jours plus
tard william nahum toutes ces vidéos en
première chaîne de séduction
humoristique alors là je me dis il a du
recul je vais écrire une vidéo alors
langue de ma vidéo était très simple
première partie je montre les conseils
de drague de williams et deuxième
parties j'applique les conseils de
william dans la vraie vie pour voir si
ça marche je tourne je monte je mets en
ligne et la polémique arrive ça dit en
gros c'est de la méchanceté gratuite du
lynchage public ne sait pas quand à 8
millions d'abonnés sdp j'avais écrit ma
vidéo de la même manière que j'allais
écrire le clash de lopez sofiane une
habile à un clash de cortège
pourquoi cette fois ci ça polémique pour
plusieurs raisons mais une
principalement celles être bien jouer
revenir williams est gentil du coup là
où les critiques sur des mecs extrême
violent qui cherchent à faire du buzz ça
marche sur quelqu'un de gentil ça
ressemble à de l'acharnement a jamais
voulu être insultant envers williams je
voulais juste me moquer gentiment de ces
techniques de drague mais visiblement
j'ai foiré alors pourquoi pas critiquer
quelqu'un de gentil me bénir un point
assez important je n'aime pas les
dragueurs professionnels et pick up
party ça plein les mecs qui veulent
prouver qu'ils peuvent choper des
numéros dans la rue qui peuvent
embrasser des inconnus qui vous explique
comment manipuler les filles pour
coucher avec leurs multiples errements
de coucher avec le plus de filles
possible et je ne comprends pas pourquoi
c'est toléré chez les mecs mais si une
fille fait une vidéo où elle embrasse
des inconnus dans la rue elle va se
faire traiter de traîner c'est un truc
que j'aime pas du tout mais moi j'ai
rangé williams dans le même sac que ces
gens là alors qu'il est vraiment gentil
il est tellement respectueux qui propose
quand même
deux mètres de distance quand tu pars
une fille l'angle de la vidéo a aussi
joué sur la polémique alors mon nom mais
c'était d'appliquer les conseils de
drague de william dans la vie sauf qu'en
fait ça dure qu'une minute dans la vidéo
c'est à la fin en plus
et du coup 80% de la vidéo c'est moi qui
me moque des techniques de drague de
williams et ça peut ressembler à de
l'acharnement personnel un dernier point
c'est mon état d'esprit quand je fais
une vidéo un état d'esprit de fdp
je vous explique quand je fais une vidéo
quand j'écris je fais comme si j'avais
aucun abonné 0 voilà ça ça m'aide à me
concentrer sur ma vidéo à écrire ce que
je veux vraiment dire et pas me faire
influencer en fait par les gens je fais
quelque chose qui me ressemble sinon on
fait j'aurais fait l'école van tournée
j'ai tort je ne peux pas ignorer le fait
que des millions de personnes ont
regardé la vidéo peuvent être influencés
que des jeunes peut-être même se dire ah
tiens c'est cool de s'acharner sur
quelqu'un de gentil non je ne veux pas
que les gens s'acharnent sur williams je
vais juste me moquer gentiment mais bon
quand tu te maquiller que tu as des
millions d'abonnés et ben ça peut avoir
des répercussions que je n'avais pas
mesure le bilan au final je suis désolé
si j'ai pu blesser williams si j'ai pu
mal influencé des gens bien moqué
gentiment parfois mais je dois le faire
intelligemment et surtout mesuré les
conséquences si je devais refaire la
vidéo et serait vraiment différente
william je suis désolé comme disait
justin bieber maintenant ça va piquer un
peu mais je vais lire certains de vos
commentaires pour vous répondre c'est
quelle genre de fils de [ __ ] à te moquer
des gens comme ça c'est juste de la
méchanceté gratuite s'applique beaucoup
d'habitudes j'adore tes vidéos mais
celle là m'a déçu on dirait plus une
critique voire presque de la méchanceté
gratuite malgré les tournières ironique
dans salut les guides se serait passé
sans problème mais pas d'anthologie je
sais pas si un autre tube heures à faire
une vidéo
ce tracé je peux pas dire en toute
logique sur la chaîne ça passe mal
auprès de certains d'entre vous pensent
avoir et ça ne dérange pas d'échouer si
c'est pour apprendre de mes erreurs en
fait faire moins d'erreurs à l'avenir si
ça pique un peu ou beaucoup énorme cette
vidéo a oui à quelques commentaires
sympas il ya même un pouce vert c'est
pas le bien de tous
c'est gratuit et méchant cyprien est
tombé bien bas et lundi cyprien c'est
pas toi qui disais à cortex insulter les
gens pour exister faut autre chose de ta
vie tu as changé alors j'ai dit ça je le
pense toujours je ne voulais pas
insulter williams je ne veux pas me
transformer en cortex non plus pas du
tout c'est pas au programme ça se fait
pas de critiquer les gens alors en vrai
si on peut très bien de critiquer les
gens il faut juste le faire dignement on
peut rire sans être blessé bravo de te
moquer de ce google
merci la correction automatique arrêtez
de dire oh il aura baisse alors que vous
regardez to what the curse a eu des
geeks
alors déjà un but aussi de nous défendre
et c'est intéressant comme commentaire
parce que je sais qu antoine ganyé le
what the cut ne parle plus des français
dans cette vidéo ce que son nombre
d'abonnés en fait on peut avoir des
répercussions fil de ses vidéos il a
pris cette décision avec de l'expérience
en fait j'aurais dû m'imprégner de sa
sagesse à la sagesse dont on gagnait les
gens qui critiquent cyprien qui arrivent
à gâcher la vie du gars se gagne majeur
et ciani sur internet a vu d'en assumer
les conséquences c'est vrai qu'il faut
réfléchir à deux fois avant que le site
ait quelque chose sur internet pour voir
ce que peut avoir des répercussions
c'est aussi vrai j'aurais pas dû être
méchant envers quelqu'un de gentil et de
moi elle ne peut pas consacrera à sa
faute si bp cyprien lui est supposé
faire des podcasts sur les chaussettes
ou les petits tracas de la vie quant à
youtube heurter ça y est quelque chose
dont il n'a pas l'habitude et propose un
contenu auquel son public ne s'attend
pas il ya évidemment des
retournez gatti alors déjà ne fait pas
que des podcasts sur les chaussettes je
fais aussi des courts métrages des
sketches et des podcasts c'est sur les
moustiques et c'est vrai que quand je
faisais mes vidéos critique en 2011 sur
des clips pour qu'en fait ça c'est
plutôt bien ça qu'aujourd'hui dans mes
vidéos comme le clash de lopez liam je
vois des commentaires
non on laisse la critique aux autres ça
n'a pas sa place sur la chaîne alors
qu'en fait je fais ce que je veux et aux
contraintes de sa riche de proposer de
la diversité c'est quand même dommage
d'avoir des millions d'abonnés de faire
ton temps la même chose voilà les
chaussettes 1,7 2,7
j'ai passé des remarqués mais j'ai
toujours une chaussette qui disparaît
par lui en français super conseils de
drague déniché par seb la frite
ça marche très bien dans la question est
comment es tu tombé sur cette vidéo il
est il un message caché à vous m'avez
fut démasqué je cherche des conseils en
séduction bonjour je m'appelle cyprien
j'ai 27 ans désolé je suis pas intéressé
les porte-manteaux locale voilà c'était
mes excuses auprès de william je voulais
me moquer gentiment et ça a ressemblé à
de l'acharnement en tout cas j'ai vu le
sang tâchent chaîne youtube du leu
prenait plutôt bien et je reçois très
fort de ta part je regarderai quand même
te prochaine vidéo je n'en parlerai pas
je ne dirai pas un mot
merci quand même ceux qui me soutiennent
je travaille sur des prochaines vidéos
je vous dis à bientôt